[Music]
on this monday night terror charges laid
in the london attack
the relief from residents that's a very
very
amazing and important step plus an
update on the sole survivor's health
who will care for the nine-year-old who
lost his family
consequences in the canadian military
after a golf game that never should have
happened
i felt before that i wasn't going to get
justice and i
now that confirms it to me the latest
senior leader to step aside in lockdown
for longer why the uk is delaying its
reopening plan
and bad attitudes at high altitudes
what's up with the rise in unruly air
passengers
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in london ontario the
suspect charged with murdering a muslim
family
in a targeted attack also now faces
terrorism charges
the 20 year old appeared by video link
in court today the prosecution announced
it is proceeding with terrorism charges
under section 83 of the criminal code
one charge relates to the murder of
salman afsal
and madiha salman the couple's 15 year
old daughter yumna
and her grandmother 74 year old talat
afsal
a second charge relates to the attempted
murder of the nine-year-old boy who
survived
fayez afsal has now been released from
the hospital and is being cared for by
extended family
a spokesperson for the family says they
are not seeking revenge
their focus is on raising awareness
about islamophobia
and making sure people know it's real
mike relay explains the charges and the
challenge
of getting a conviction
the flowers at the makeshift memorial
have begun to wilt the messages look
weathered
but the anger about islamophobia in
london ontario
is as strong as ever islamic people do
something
they always said it's a terrorist what
is the difference
about this this actually guy who did
this
this guy is 20 20-year-old nathaniel
veltman who allegedly drove his truck
into the afzal salomon family
killing four and injuring a
nine-year-old boy clad in an orange
jumpsuit
velman learned of new charges monday
along with four counts of first degree
murder
and one count of attempted murder
prosecutors now also accuse him
of terrorism imam arijanwar says even
though prime minister justin trudeau
called the attack terrorism
the muslim community still remembers how
terror charges were never laid
in the quebec city moss shooting of
2017.
the charges in the london case he says
allowed the community
to exhale i think overall there was some
pessimism some skepticism
but the fact that it was done the way it
was supposed to be
that's a very very amazing and important
step canadian authorities have
historically been reluctant to file
terrorism charges
because it's incumbent on law
enforcement to prove the motive behind
the offense
which isn't always supported by hard
evidence the fact that they've now laid
charges tells me that
the investigation has uncovered
something that
gives rise to the ability to show that
it was done for
either political religious or
ideological reasons
a publication ban has been placed on the
pre-trial proceedings so
it will be a while before any facts are
known publicly
for now say terrorism experts the
upgraded charges
send a message i mean let's face it the
terrorism label
carries impact right it has significance
in how the broader public
sees these kinds of crimes a
spokesperson for the family says the
sole survivor of the attack
nine-year-old faiz
is out of hospital and expected to make
a full recovery
global news has agreed not to show any
pictures of the boy at the request of
the family
for now he's face timing with friends
and is surrounded by loved ones
including his other grandmother
and despite a dozen families both muslim
and non-muslim
reaching out to the mosque in hopes of
adopting the boy
it's believed his future will be
residing with one of his two uncles
who live here in canada donna
all right mike trolley in london tonight
thanks yet another senior leader of the
canadian military is stepping aside
this time it is lieutenant general mike
rouleau who went golfing with the former
chief of the defense staff jonathan
vance
who is under military police
investigation for sexual misconduct
rilo has oversight authority over the
military police
it's hard to keep track of all the
dominoes falling in what appears to be a
cozy old boys club in the senior ranks
of the canadian armed forces
the military has now lost its two top
commanders
mercedes stephenson has been on this
story from the beginning
and explains how people are reacting
is there no morals is there no integrity
is there no
um duty
that anybody's respecting anymore major
kelly brennan is the woman who triggered
a reckoning over sexual misconduct in
the canadian military
when she came forward to global news in
february with allegations against
canada's former top soldier
retired general jonathan vance
allegations he denies
the now notorious chummy golf game on a
private military course between two of
canada's top military commanders and
vance
underscored brennan's belief senior
officials don't take the issue seriously
and would back vance i felt before that
i wasn't going to get justice
and i now that confirms it to me brennan
alleged that vance claimed to own the
military police
and said that he was untouchable today
vice chief of the defense staff
lieutenant general mike rulo resigned
after the golf game exposed by the media
led to days of intense public pressure
and displeasure from the prime
minister's office and cabinet
it shows very poor judgment
and sends entirely the wrong message to
the whole country
in a letter general rulo defended his
actions as concern about a former
colleague's welfare
but also acknowledged i understand how
such an activity could lead some
to perceive a potential conflict of
interest and controversy
given the current context but nothing
could be further from the truth
for this i am sorry he said no matters
related to the investigations were
discussed
i think it's very appropriate for him to
resign rulo's presence was particularly
problematic because he oversees the
military police
the same force that is investigating
jonathan vance for sexual misconduct
but there's more than a perceived
problem with rulo's presence
according to professor megan mckenzie
it's beyond a conflict of interest
it's really you know i just think a
display of invincibility
the future of the head of the royal
canadian navy vice admiral craig baines
remains unclear on monday he apologized
again in a statement to global news
saying his focus
should have been on the victims
conservative leader aaron o'toole says
it's time for the liberal government to
step up there is
zero leadership from justin trudeau and
minister
sajan that is setting a tone
of no accountability the minister of
national defense was
unavailable for an on-camera interview
with global news
but he is facing increasing pressure to
get his department
under control donna
hi mercedes thanks the military
commander removed from his post as head
of vaccine logistics last month has
apparently filed a legal challenge
the canadian press is reporting lawyers
from major general danny forte are
asking
the federal court for a judicial review
of that decision
fortan was removed may 14 after an
allegation of sexual misconduct
according to cp the court application
says the decision to remove and not
reassign him was
unreasonable lack procedural fairness
and involved
improper political interference in the
military chain of command
well after months of restrictions there
are new signs more canadians can look
forward to a better summer
this will be our summer of hope and
healing from this pandemic
tomorrow bc moves to step two of its
reopening plan
recreational travel within the province
will be allowed again
outdoor gatherings can expand to up to
50 people and movie theaters and banquet
holes can reopen
bc is reporting 68 new cases today
that's the lowest
since late september moderna is boosting
its
vaccine shipments to canada over 9
million doses are now expected to arrive
in june moderner had been struggling to
meet its second quarter commitment to
canada
this increase means the company will
exceed its original target and deliver
12.9 million doses
more ontarians are now eligible for an
earlier second dose
people who had their first shot on or
before may 9 and who live in one of
seven hot spot regions
where the delta variant is spreading can
now book their second shot
the much more transmissible delta
variant first identified in india
is on track to be the dominant strain in
ontario by early summer
it is already dominant in the uk and
today because of that
prime minister boris johnson said it's
too soon to lift england's final stage
of public health restrictions
the delta variant is driving a surge in
cases there
especially among unvaccinated young
people
redmond shannon explains what's
happening and why the situation is being
closely watched
around the world despite these
anti-lockdown protests
and england's very low covet 19 death
rate prime minister boris johnson has
put the brakes
on the country's final stage of
reopening by being cautious now
we have the chance in the next four
weeks to save
many thousands of lives by vaccinating
millions more people johnson has pushed
back the reopening of nightclubs and
large events by four weeks to july 19th
the more infectious delta variant is to
blame
it's now dominant in the uk we're seeing
cases growing by about
64 percent per week and in the worst
affected areas
it's doubling every week young people
are now the main source of rising
infections
less likely to get sick but more likely
to mix in britain's
already open pubs if this is locked on
it's a
the gentlest possible social restriction
you could imagine
there's no point in saying oh let's live
with it or put our all our cares aside
the virus would love that and we've got
to stay ahead of this virus
on monday public health england said the
pfizer and astrazeneca vaccines are
more effective than previously thought
against the delta variant in preventing
hospital admissions especially after two
doses
but even after one the data is promising
good news for canada which has been
prioritizing
a one dose strategy some experts say
those numbers and the summer weather
will give canada time to catch up
being outdoors sitting outdoors good
ventilation
people not being proximate to each other
i think those factors all play a
favorable role
here in london prime minister boris
johnson says the government will review
the infection and hospitalization data
in two weeks and if it looks favorable
england's final reopening date could
be brought forward again donna
redmond shannon in london thanks nato
leaders from europe and north america
have some strong words for russia and
china tonight the political and military
allies at the nato summit
set a road map for how to deal with
china's rising power and
russia's continuing threat cyber
security and climate change are also on
the agenda
abigail beeman is in brussels traveling
with the prime minister
world leaders trying to figure out how
to modernize a 70-year military alliance
may have missed the mark with the photo
op
but nato's secretary general's message
was on target
our relationship with russia is at its
lowest point
since the end of the cold war this is
due to
russia's aggressive actions the alliance
slamming those actions as a security
threat
while nations clamor for u.s president
joe biden's ear before his meeting with
russian president vladimir putin
wednesday
i'm not looking for conflict with russia
but that we will respond if russia
continues its harmful activities
on china allies agreed the communist
state presents systemic challenges and
coercive policies there are 30 members
of nato and each member has a very
different relationship with china
the goal present unity in a post-trump
world
yet some members are closer to putin i
spent
26 years of my life in cold war
believe me it's bad so don't do that we
can't be can't be naive about about
putin's intentions
prime minister justin trudeau said the
alliance can deal with both russia and
china
we can certainly walk and chew gum at
the same time recognize
russia as a very present and real threat
which is
why we have the enhanced forward
presence that canada's part of
why canada has troops in ukraine ukraine
not a member of nato but wants to be
canada while offering support won't
clearly state its position
the heart of nato is article 5 an attack
upon one is equals one attack upon all
and if you admit ukraine to being a
member of nato then suddenly
nato is faced with a question of whether
wants to be at war with russia cyber
security and for the first time
climate were also on the agenda
stoltenberg thanked canada for offering
to launch a new
nato policy center bringing together
expertise
specifically on climate and security but
that won't be ready until at least
twenty
twenty three abigail beeman global news
brussels
allowing indigenous canadians to use
their traditional names
coming up what the federal government
has finally agreed to
[Music]
the federal government is pushing ahead
with a controversial court case
involving indigenous children
taken from their families by the child
welfare system the case being heard in
federal court challenges a pair of
rulings by the canadian human rights
tribunal
awarding damages to indigenous children
and their families
the federal government is arguing the
tribunal did not have legal authority to
award
individual damages and is seeking a
class action instead
the case builds on what is known as
jordan's principle
it's named after a five-year-old
manitoba boy who died
while the provincial and federal
governments bickered over who would pay
for his care
the federal government is finally
allowing indigenous people including
people of inuit and metis background to
reclaim their traditional names on
passports and other federal id
names that were banished by bureaucrats
and replaced with anglicized names
the traditional names given to
indigenous children
carry deep cultural meaning at the
aklavik anglican school in the northwest
territories a young inuit girl named
masek became
alice she would not hear her original
name
until she returned home
the change was one of 94 calls to action
made in the truth and reconciliation
commission reports six years ago
most have yet to be implemented
what they're picking and choosing out of
the trc calls to action
are the stuff that politically doesn't
cost them so on the day that they are in
court against indigenous kids
i think it just stinks of hypocrisy
ahead canada's refugee board accused of
discrimination by a woman who says she
was escaping torture
and death threats
an ongoing emergency in illinois tonight
an explosion at a chemical plant sparked
huge fires and fears of an environmental
disaster
the plant produces greases lubricants
and cleaners
people living close by have been forced
to leave authorities are letting the
fire burn itself
out to try to prevent toxic chemicals
from washing into a nearby river
a woman from gaza is speaking out
tonight after canada's refugee board
denied her claim for asylum
the woman came to canada after she says
she was tortured by members
of hamas and she believes she would face
almost certain death
if she was sent back kamil karamali has
her story
[Music]
rawand al-mobayad is safe with her
children in her ontario
home for now far away from war-torn gaza
and the memories that still haunt her
it's raised my anxiety if i'm thinking
about it so
i try just to to erase this
she says she was ripped from her family
home by hamas security forces in 2016.
taken away for seven days where she
claims she was
tortured and threatened with rape yeah
hitting and
verbally insulting me she says it was
all retaliation for reporting the rape
of a 12 year old girl
by a senior hamas militant when
al-mubayad was released fearing for her
safety she eventually came to canada
but she says nothing could have prepared
her for the way she was treated during a
hearing
at the immigration and refugee board of
canada in 2020.
it's almost destroyed me it's one of the
worst experience i will ever had
she says irb adjudicator paul aryama was
demeaning and dismissive and claims he
prevented her from telling her story
and you are pretty well repeating what
what you really
wrote down ariyama also asked her why
she didn't go to hamas for protection
after she reported the little girl's
rape even though he knew she said she
was tortured by the militant group
the adjudicator believed the approach to
be logical because hamas had listened to
her before
when she initially reported the rapist
and he was punished
he's like questioning every answer i
give and somehow it was wrong
aryama rejected her claim saying he
didn't believe her
adding that her answers were vague and
that she didn't provide sufficient
evidence
i think this claimant didn't have a
chance to present her case
i think she was shut down in the first
moments of the hearing
in a phone interview with global news
the adjudicator auriemma
denied any wrongdoing and says he has
never acted
improperly in his 30 years on the
refugee board
yes i'm fine i'm fine distraught and
distressed
but not down and out just yet after
global news stepped in the government
is working on a settlement in
al-mubayed's case
which would allow her claim to be
re-heard by the board
i hope i'm safe now and my kids are safe
kamela karamali global news
lots of people are itching to get
traveling again and the number of planes
in the air
is already approaching what it was
before the pandemic
this is a snapshot of all the planes in
the air today
thanks to flight radar 24 and this is
what it looked like in march of 2020
when the pandemic began the u.s
especially
is back in full flight and as jackson
proskow reports the number of badly
behaved passengers
is also soaring there's something in the
air
that has passengers causing disruption
this flight from los angeles to atlanta
was diverted after an off-duty flight
attendant became
unruly at one point the pilot called out
for help
and then you hear the pilot from the
cockpit going if there's any large men
on board please come to the front of the
plane immediately we have a crazy
passenger
one week earlier a passenger allegedly
tried to storm the cockpit on a flight
from los angeles to nashville
and the week before that a southwest
airlines flight attendant lost two teeth
after an angry passenger punched her in
the face
passengers are behaving belligerently
they are becoming aggressive
hostile they are verbally abusive and
oftentimes they've been violent it seems
pandemic era travel has led to an
epidemic of bad behavior
u.s airlines have reported nearly 3 000
incidents of unruly passengers so far
this year
way more than normal we are on track to
have 60
times the number of unruly passengers as
we might have had
in a typical year the situation is so
concerning
some u.s airlines have suspended alcohol
service
while airlines in canada and around the
world are bracing for a possible uptick
in aggressive behavior
as passengers return just everyone is
acting crazy on planes now it's making
people not want to fly
there's no official explanation for
what's happening
flight attendants point out most
incidents involve confrontations over
masks
as more of us stretch our wings after a
year-long layover
airlines are asking for patience while
warning those who lash out could face
stiff fines
or the prospect of being grounded for
life
jackson prosko global news washington
patience kindness that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen tonight's here canada
is this view of lake winnipeg thanks for
watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye